[Music]  TBS has been so happy with us they asked  if we could develop some more  programming for their network and I  think we came up with a new legal drama  that people are really going to love  here's a sneak peek there's one attorney  in Dallas you don't want to tangle with  you know how about I cut you off right  there  case dismissed his name is food faith  lawyer but the question is can you look  me in the face and tell me you did not  kill your wife no I I can't look I  killed her okay take me away it's fine  Your Honor I rest my case  watch next week to see a food face  lawyer has met his match the face millet  only TBS  so what for that on CBS  [Applause]